[Music]
everyone's seen the hunger games i want
to talk about something because the
hunger games is starting to dominate our
culture in a way that's borderline weird
you've seen this movie right
okay well according to a new study that
just came out the hunger games is now
surpassing twilight
as the primary cultural influence on new
baby names
baby names yeah so finally some good
news for my two children crossbow and
woody
is there some harrelson
i wish i had gone for that
woody harrelson is such a cute little
girl yeah
she's my little darling yeah she's she's
a cutie daddy loves you woody harrelson
[Laughter]
can you believe that though they're
naming their kids
it's crazy
uh rick santorum now out of the race you
all know that he uh yeah he's
a day after dropping out of the
presidential race rick santorum is
trying to figure out his next move
that's right
for uh for now santorum's return to his
previous job traveling to small towns
across america and forcing them to
outlaw dancing
everyone uh everyone of course wondering
who is mitt romney's running mate going
to be yeah yeah everyone
well not you
yeah i don't really uh when asked about
mitt romney's vice presidential pick
herman cain suggested that he would
bring some excitement to the ticket
yeah then he asked if mitt romney's wife
is single
president george w bush's news you hear
this he's got complaints uh-huh yeah at
a conference yesterday george w bush
said he wishes people would stop
referring to his tax policy as the bush
tax cuts
yeah he also wishes people would stop
referring to his presidency as the eight
year oopsie
[Applause]
i like that move uh
in alabama a meth lab was found
operating inside a walmart bathroom
[Applause]
on the bright side walmart's finally
selling products that are made in
america
[Applause]
we can do better
all right
who needs that chinese mask oh that
chinese method is awesome
according to a new study that just came
out it's possible for women to
experience a second kind of orgasm
yeah yes still no word on what the first
kind is
i'm serious i have no idea
this is not a joke
yesterday an alabama man was sentenced
to three days in jail for wearing saggy
pants to his court hearing
yeah saggy pants yeah of course in jail
they're not called saggy pants they're
called a head start
which uh now folks
we we're together for an hour so let's
be friends
let's not turn on one another now
this is crazy conservatives in arizona
are trying to pass a law that says that
life begins two weeks before conception
two weeks before conception
yes so apparently a lot of my dates went
much better than i thought
i didn't know
[Music]
burger king ladies and gentlemen burger
king has announced they are testing a
new bacon
sundae
let me say that again
burger king is testing a bacon sundae
burger king also announced it's changing
its slogan from have it your way to die
humans die
[Applause]
[Music]